ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE LIMON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
CARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RAY IS [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
ROBERT REAVIS [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SAU SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
MR HOLDEN.
LET US PRAY.
LORD WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE OF THIS LEGISLATIVE
ASSEMBLY.
REFER A THAT YOU WOULD MAKE A
LIGHT THE HEAVINESS OF
RESPONSIBILITY THE UNDERTAKEN
THEIR ROLE AS LEADERS.
OF THIS GREAT STATE.
OR YOUR WORD REMINDS US THAT
YOUR YOKE IS EASY AND YOUR
BURDEN IS LIGHT.
AS WE CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH LET US REMEMBER THE
TREMENDOUS ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND NOT FORGET
THE PAIN AND SUFFERING ANCESTORS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN TOWARD
CROSSING THE ATLANTIC.
NOT AS IMMIGRANTS BUT AS
INSULATE PEOPLE WHO SURVIVED ON
HEARD OF DEGRADATION.
AND CRUELTY.
MAY WE NEVER FORGET THAT FREEDOM
HAS NOT BEEN FREE.
AND EVEN TODAY WE LABOR UNDER
THE RESIDUE OF OVER FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS OF SLAVERY.
AND JIM CROW.
LORD WE THANK YOU FOR THEIR
STRENGTH.
AND COURAGE TO SURVIVE AND
THRIVE UNDER UNIMAGINABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
LET US BE INSPIRED BY THE
COUNTLESS UNSUNG HEROES WHOSE
COURAGE FADE.
AND PERSISTENCE FOR BETTER DAY.
POWER TO US TO OUR BETTER SELVES.
MOST IMPORTANTLY.
LET US NOT FORGET THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS GREAT
STATE.
AND NATION.
NOW GROUND AS LORD A NEW SPIRIT
OF UNDERSTANDING.
AND HEALING.
THAT WE MAY LEARN FROM ONE
ANOTHER.
BILL TOGETHER AND ALL BE MADE
NEW AGAIN AND YOUR SITE
[inaudible]
PAYMENT.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
ENJOYING S. FOR THIS FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS
PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE RECITE THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
PUBLIC.
WHICH STANDS. ONE NATION.
INDIVISIBLE [inaudible]
SAW.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO PLAYERS AGENT JANUARY
TWENTY ONE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE SUMMIT AT NINE AM THE
AUDIBLE COVER MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY BESIDES SHE
BROKE THE DOCILE SO THAT THE
DENNIS.
THIS IS THE CLERK DAVID OVER
READING THE ROLES CALL MR GLORIA
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL.
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
SIEGES.
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
THE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAM GRAY. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALDERON.
CHEN [inaudible]
COOPER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MR GLORIA HERE RECOGNIZE FOR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW SPEAKER
RENDON AND MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM
JONES SAWYER MATHIS AND WEBER TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE ARE PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER GLORIA YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN FOR THE JOURNAL WANT
TO NOTE THAT MISS --
MISTER MAX'S GAS WILL BE SEATED
AT HIS DESK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBBER'S GUESTS WILL BE SEATED
IN THE AREA OF THE MEMBERS DESK
FOR BLACK HISTORY MONTH CEREMONY
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY BILL RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PATTERSON
CRISTINA GARCIA RUBIO AND WICKS
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
WE HAVE VERY SPECIAL GUEST WITH
US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER SPEAKER MISTER SPEAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS
IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO STAND ON
THE ASSEMBLY FOR FLOOR IN SPEAK
ABOUT LILIANA.
FOR SHE'S BEEN THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF MEXICO IN SACRAMENTO
FOR MOST OF MY TIME AS SPEAKER
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES
TO TALK AND WORK FOR BETTER
RELATIONS BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
MEXICO.
HER EFFORTS WERE INVALUABLE WHEN
I JOIN THE ASSEMBLY DELEGATION
MEXICO TO DISCUSS --
TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS AND
EDUCATION POLLUTION CONTROL AND
OTHER ISSUES WHERE WE CAN FOSTER
PROGRESS IN COOPERATION.
HER EDUCATION HER TEACHING AND
HER SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
MEXICO EARNED HER THE RANK OF
AMBASSADOR IN NOVEMBER WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE CELEBRATING TODAY.
SHE HAS SERVED IN EMBASSIES IN
PARIS IN WASHINGTON DC.
BEFORE BECOMING THE CONSUL
GENERAL --
HERE BE QUITE EASY TO BE
INTIMIDATED BY ALL OF HER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THERE ARE
MANY.
WE KNOW HER AS BEING INCREDIBLY
DOWN TO EARTH AS SHE SOMEBODY
WHO I OFTEN RUN INTO IT MY
FAVORITE BAKER HERE IN TOWN --
MET AND SHE SOMEBODY THAT --
THAT WORKS AS HARD UNDER THE
CAPITOL DOME --
AS SHE DOES ANYWHERE ELSE IT'S
GOOD TO KNOW THAT SHE'S GONNA BE
CONTINUING AS THE CONSUL GENERAL.
EVEN AS SHE ENJOYS THE WELL
DESERVED RANK OF AMBASSADOR
[inaudible]
AND MISTER.
MEMBERS MISTER MEDINA YOU TWO
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE.
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
AND AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO BI NATIONAL RELATIONS
COMMITTEE.
I RISE TO HONOR AMBASSADOR
LILLEY UNFIT ALLEN.
WHO IS REMAIN COMMITTED?
IN HER EFFORTS TO ADVANCE THE
EXISTING CULTURAL SOCIAL AND
TRADE RELATIONS BETWEEN MEXICO
AND CALIFORNIA.
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH AMBASSADOR FOR INTER
PREVIOUS ROLE AS COUNSEL.
GENERAL OF MEXICO IN SACRAMENTO.
THIS LEGISLATURE WORKING WITH.
AMBASSADOR FOR RARE HAVE
CONTINUED TO STRENGTHEN OUR
IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AT HEARING TO THE LEVELS OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT WERE SIGNED.
BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH EMPHASIS ON CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION TRADE AND TOURISM.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE PRESIDENT
OF MEXICO ANDRES MANUEL LOPEZ --
BUT OTHER WORDS VISITING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE.
CONTINUING OUR WORK
CONGRADULATIONS TO AMBASSADOR
FOR RARE UNDER APPOINTMENT TO
THE RANK OF AMBASSADOR WE
APPLIED HER.
OUTSTANDING RECORD FOR HER
LEADERSHIP.
AND MISTER SPEAKER YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS.
THIS RESOLUTION ARE RECOGNIZING
THE WORK AND FRIENDSHIP OF
CONSUL GENERAL LILIANA
.
FOR MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING SOME SPECIAL GUESTS
THE FLOOR IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
NINETEEN STUDENTS FROM CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO ARE BEING
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
JOINING CAL POLY PRESIDENT JEFF
ARMSTRONG ON THE FLOOR WE HAVE
SAMANTHA GALLEY SEE NOW SAMANTHA
WAS THE CENTRAL COAST NATIVE SHE
HAILS FROM SANTA MARIA
CALIFORNIA.
SHE TOOK FIRST IN TEAM TACK
INTERN FIVE OTHER WARDS OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NATIONAL SOCIETY
OF WOMEN ENGINEERS CONFERENCE.
ALSO ON THE FLOOR IS JACK
JASMINE FISHY ME SHE'S THE
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT AND IS
REPRESENTING CAL POLY AS THE
WINNERS OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BALLOT FULL COMPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
THE STUDENTS AS WELL AS THE ONES
IN THE GALLERY.
GO MUSTANGS
.
MEMBERS MOVING BRIEFLY MOTIONS
MISTER GLORIA YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE TO HAVE A
GUEST AT HER DESK TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
ASSEMBLY MISTER JONES SAWYER HAS
GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MISTER JONES WHERE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE LAURIE
BETTIS AND BARCA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM AND TOM JACOBSON SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF ADVANCEMENT.
THE NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM OPEN
IN MY DISTRICT AT EXPOSITION
PARK IN.
NINETEEN THIRTEEN IT IS THE
LARGEST NATURAL AND HISTORICAL
MUSEUM WEST OF THE MISSISSIPPI
SECOND ONLY TO THE SMITHSONIAN.
ITS COLLECTIONS INCLUDE CLOSE TO
THIRTY FIVE MILLION SPEECH
SPECIMENS AND ARTIFACTS THAT
DATE BACK. FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION YEARS.
HI THEY WILL HAVE NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
WHERE THE BUILDING WILL BE
OPENED UP YOU'LL BE MORE
LIGHTING?
SO THAT MY GRAND CHILD WHO WILL
BE TURNING ONE SOON WON'T BE
AFRAID OF THE BIG LONG DINOSAUR.
THAT'S IN THE BUILDING RIGHT NOW.
THE NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM IS AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR ALL OF
OUR SOUTHERN.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
PLEASE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM TO THE STATE CAPITOL.
THANK YOU.
AND MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
AYE I JUST WANTED --
TO POINT OUT THAT MY COLLEAGUE
IN IS WELCOME COVERED A LOT OF
GROUND BUT HE LEFT OUT THE FACT
THAT THE NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM
IS ALSO THE HOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE DINOSAUR.
AUGUSTINE OFFICE MORRISSEY
.
MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE SPECIAL
GUESTS HERE IN THE CHAMBER AND
WE WANT TO CALL ON MISTER MATHIS
FOR HIS SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MY NAME SAM MY NAME'S JEFFERSON.
SAY MY NAME JEFFERSON.
AND I'M FOUR YEARS OLD.
AND IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE.
SAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE
AND MISTER KING [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MR TAKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM.
PROUD TO RECOGNIZE THE FOURTH
GRADE CLASS FROM.
STAR KING ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WHO'S YOUR BUSINESS IN
SACRAMENTO TODAY THERE ARE THEY
ARE FROM MY DAUGHTER'S
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO SO REALLY WANNA.
JUST THANK ALL THE THE STARRCADE
CLASS FOR COMING TODAY AND
JOINING US THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
MY ARMS GETTING WORK OUT MEMBERS
THIS PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL MANAGEABLE IN THE CHAMBER.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A SPECIAL
INTRODUCTION ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DAVID CHIU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GIPSON KALRA
LOW.
AND PATTERSON.
WE WELCOME THE JAMES IRVINE
FOUNDATION LEADERSHIP AWARD
HONOREES.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN ON BEHALF OF
THOSE MEMBERS THAT I LISTED THEY
ARE IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
AS I CALL YOUR NAME FROM MISTER
DAVID CHOOSE DISTRICT IS CHERYL
AND ADAMS.
CEO OF LARKIN YOUTH SERVICES IN
SAN FRANCISCO FROM MISTER
GIBSON'S DISTRICT IS DOCTOR
RELATING BACHELOR CEO OF THE MLK
JUNIOR COMMUNITY HOSPITAL IN LOS
ANGELES.
FROM MR EVAN LOW'S DISTRICT IS
EILEEN RICHARD ST.
CEO OF DOWNTOWN STREETS TEAM IN
SAN JOSE.
AND FROM MISTER KALRA IS
DISTRICT IS EUNICE LAND NICHOLS
VICE PRESIDENT OF ENCORE DOT ORG
IN SAN JOSE.
AND FROM MISTER PATTERSON'S
DISTRICT IS YEAH MY LEG G.
WELCOME THEM TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO A
SPECIAL CEREMONY.
HONORING BLACK HISTORY MONTH
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WANT TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE ACR NINETEEN WEBER.
WITH THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING.
LOCAL.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETEEN BY SOME MEMORABLE WEBER
AND OTHERS ROSE IT'S A BLACKISH
AMOUNT.
DOCTOR WEBER YOUR RECOGNIZE AT
YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ONCE AGAIN I RISE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
AS WE PRESENT ACR NINETEEN IN
HONOR OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
THE STORY OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH
ITSELF BEGAN IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN
ABOUT A HALF A CENTURY AFTER THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT THAT
ABOLISHED SLAVERY IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IT WAS IN SEPTEMBER THAT A
HARVARD TRAINED HISTORIAN.
DOCTOR CARTER G. WOODSON.
WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF MISS
EDUCATION OF THE NEGRO?
REALIZE THAT MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THE HISTORY
AND CONTRIBUTION OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEREFORE IN NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
AND FEBRUARY.
THE FIRST NEGRO HISTORY WEEK
[inaudible]
TOOK PLACE.
FEBRUARY WAS CHOSEN IT
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH AS THE
SHORTEST MONTH OF THE YEAR.
BUT WAS CHOSEN BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
AND FREDERICK DOUGLASS. TWO
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY BELIEVED
HAD A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
CHANGING THE PROJECT THREE OF
THE LIFE OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
OVER THE YEARS BLACK HISTORY
MONTH HAS CONTINUED TO GROW AND
TO DEVELOP BLACK HISTORY WEEK I
SHOULD SAY.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX THAT WE BEGIN TO
TALK ABOUT BLACK HISTORY MONTH
MORE THAN JUST THE SECOND WEEK
OF FEBRUARY.
BUT THE ENTIRE MONTH OF FEBRUARY.
AND OF COURSE IN THIS HOUSE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR AYE BY EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILLIE
BROWN.
SIGNED INTO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROCLAMATION REGARDING MARTIN
LUTHER KING'S BIRTHDAY.
ONCE AGAIN GIVING CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN ONE DAY TO CELEBRATE
AND RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
IT HAS BEEN ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS WHO WILL BE IN AUGUST.
THAT THE FIRST AFRICANS CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY LISTED THEM AS TWENTY AN
ODD NEGROES.
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN.
TWENTY THEY WERE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAD BEEN CAPTURED ON A SHIP.
BY THE DUTCH.
AN EVENTUALLY SOLD AND TRADED
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WERE.
THE FIRST TO COME.
AND THEY WERE LISTED AND SOLD AS
INVOLUNTARY LABORERS AND
INDENTURED SERVANTS.
THIS WAS NOT THE BEGINNING OF
SLAVERY AS MOST PEOPLE THINK.
BECAUSE SHORTLY AFTER THAT TIME
THEY HAD CONTRACTS TO SAID THAT
THEY WOULD WORK. FOR A SPECIFIED
PERIOD OF TIME.
AND THEN THEY WOULD GAIN THEIR
FREEDOM JUST LIKE ALL OTHER
INDENTURED SERVANTS DID.
AND IT IT WITHIN THREE OR FOUR
YEARS SOME OF THEM WERE LISTED
AS LAND OWNERS.
SO IT'S INCORRECT TO BELIEVE
THAT THE FIRSTPERSON WHO CAME
HERE WERE SLAVES.
THEY WERE NOT THERE WHEN
INDENTURED SERVANTS LIKE SO MANY
OTHERS.
THEY CAME HERE YEAR BEFORE THE
MAYFLOWER.
WHICH WAS IN.
SIXTEEN TWENTY SO YEAR BEFORE
THE MAYFLOWER AFRICANS WILL ON
THIS CONTINENT.
WORKING TO DEVELOP AMERICA AND
TO MAKE A CONTRIBUTION.
EVENTUALLY THE SLAVE TRADE DID
DEVELOP.
AND IT BECAME THE WORST SYSTEM
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
SLAVERY HAD ALWAYS EXISTED IN
AMERICA IT ALWAYS EXISTED AROUND
THE WORLD.
BUT THE KIND OF SLAVERY THAT
EXIST IN AMERICA WAS UNKNOWN TO
ANY HUMAN KIND.
IT WAS NOT JUST AS SLAVERY FOR
LABOR TEMPORARILY IT WAS THE
SLAVERY OF THE SOUL.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO NOT ONLY
IMPRISONED THEMSELVES BUT FOR
GENERATIONS AND GENERATIONS TO
COME.
EVENTUALLY EVERY LAW WAS WRITTEN
TO PUT TO PREVENT THEM FROM
HAVING ANY RIGHTS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND TO IT AND AND OFTENTIMES TO
LEGALIZE THE BRUTAL BRUTALITY
THAT EXISTED.
AND OF COURSE THE OWNERSHIP OF
INDIVIDUAL SO THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY BE SOLD THE COULD BE
BREED IT AND THEY COULD BE
KILLED WITHOUT IN CONSEQUENCE.
DESPITE THAT SOME FIFTY MILLION
AFRICANS WITH STOLEN FROM THE
CONTINENT OF AFRICA.
ONLY FIFTEEN MILLION MADE IT TO
THE UNITED STATES.
WHICH SPEAKS ABOUT THE BRUTALITY
OF THE MIDDLE PASSAGE.
THE MANY WHO DIED ALONG THE WAY
WHO TOOK ILL.
THE MINI WHO COMMITTED SUICIDE
ALONG THE WAY.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YOU
HAVE THE RATE BEING OF THE
CONTINENT OF AFRICA OF SOME OF
ITS STRONG THIS.
YOUNGEST INDIVIDUALS.
WHICH ALSO WE CAN THE CONTINENT.
AND MADE IT SUBJECT TO A NUMBER
OF COLONIAL ACTIVITIES THAT
OCCUR AND EVENTUALLY THE TAKING
OF MUCH OF THE CONTINENT OF
AFRICA INTO COLONIAL RULE.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT.
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
CONTINUE TO GROW. TO DEVELOP. TO
BE OPTIMISTIC. TO HAVE VISIONS
AND DREAMS.
AND TO MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THIS COUNTRY THAT HAS BEEN
DOCUMENTED THROUGHOUT THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY WHETHER
THROUGH THE OFFICE OF PATENTS.
OR OTHER PLACES WHERE WE SEE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE MADE NOT
ONLY IN AGRICULTURE.
BUT IN SCIENCE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF NUMEROUS NUMEROUS INVENTIONS.
AND EVEN MORE RECENTLY WE ALL
BECAME AWARE.
OF THE HUMAN CALCULATORS.
AND THE ROLE OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN IN IN THE SPACE
TRAVEL ITSELF.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT AS WE COME
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT ACR.
NINETEEN THE BLACK CAUCUS
RECOGNIZES THE TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE.
AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE
MADE TO CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU GO BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE YOU WILL SEE THE HISTORY
THAT'S ON THE WALL.
OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS MADE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK AND TO
MAKE THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS.
WITH THE ONLY INDIVIDUALS GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY STOLEN
FROM THE COUNTRY.
WHAT TO THIS COUNTRY?
WORKED WITHOUT ANY COMPENSATION.
AND THE ONLY ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED TO HAVE BEEN
BASICALLY TREATED BRUTALLY.
AND NEVER GIVEN REPARATIONS.
WHICH THIS CONTINUE TO BE A
CHALLENGE THAT'S THE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO AYE ASKS THAT YOU JOIN US.
WITH AB ACR.
NINETEEN AND WE URGE EVERYONE TO
CELEBRATE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS NOT ONLY DOING
BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
BUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THROUGHOUT THE THE LOT THE
ENTIRE A YEAR.
AND THAT THIS RESOLUTION
ENCOURAGES THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO THAT.
AND TO OUR KNOWLEDGE THE TALENTS
THE ACHIEVEMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO THE STATE IN THIS NATION
AND THE WORLD FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR.
NINETEEN CHAIR RECOGNIZES MISTER
MURATSUCHI FROM HIS DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
I RISE. TO SUPPORT [inaudible]
ACR. NINETEEN TO CELEBRATE BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
YOU KNOW I'M A SUBMIT FOR MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
I DID NOT LEARN ENOUGH ABOUT
AFTER AMERICAN HISTORY DURING MY
CHILDHOOD.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL COLLEGE.
WHEN?
I STARTED TAKING ETHNIC STUDIES
CLASSES.
THAT I STARTED TO LEARN ABOUT
THE COMMONALITIES.
AND HISTORIES OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IN AMERICA.
INCLUDING THE HISTORY OF ASIANS
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
AS A YOUNG COLLEGE MAN I READ
THE AUTOBIOGRAPHY OF MALCOLM X..
AND I RECOGNIZE IMMEDIATELY THAT
ANGER.
AGAINST RACISM BECAUSE IT'S THAT
SAME ANGER.
THAT I AM PERSONALLY FELT EVERY
TIME I'VE BEEN CALLED.
A* OR*.
AND WHEN I LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
ANGER AND AFTER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE LONG TOO
LONG HISTORY OF RACISM IN
AMERICA AGAINST AFTER AMERICANS.
I RECOGNIZE THAT ANGER BECAUSE
IT IS THE SAME ANGER THAT
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
NO. ONE AN ENTIRE RACE IS
PROFILED AS A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT AND INCARCERATED IN
AMERICAN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
AND SO IT IS FROM THIS PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF KNOWING THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER OF KNOWING
OUR HISTORY.
THAT I RISE IN SUPPORT. TO HONOR
BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
YES THANK YOU MEMBERS IT IS
CLEARLY AN HONOR TO STAND.
IN RECOGNITION OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH.
I WOULD LIKE.
TO PAY TRIBUTE TO THE
EXTRAORDINARY MEN AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THIS COUNTRY
IN OUR SOCIETY.
AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING
WITH SOME OF THE MOST ADMIRABLE.
HARDWORKING AND SELL STOCK
SACRIFICING OFFICERS WERE INDEED
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
I KNOW THAT IT IS THE TRADITION
OF COURAGE SELF SACRIFICE AND
INNOVATION WITHIN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THAT HELPS MAKE OUR SOCIETY
STRONG.
I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
FOR GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THIS RECOGNITION AND I ALSO
THINK THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS FOR SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
MR BONTA HAS RECOGNIZED RICHARD
S..
THANK YOU SPEAKER MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
LGBT CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
A C. R. NINETEEN RECOGNIZING
FEBRUARY.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS PLOT
BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
LGBT Q. INDIVIDUALS HAVE PLAYED
A KEY AND VIBRANT ROLE WITHIN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE MADE
IMPACTFUL CONTRIBUTIONS.
OF FOR THE ONGOING FIGHT FOR
SOCIAL AND JUSTICE LET'S TEACH
OUR CHILDREN TO NEW NAMES FROM
THE HEROES OF BLACK HISTORY.
MARSHA P. JOHNSON AND BAYARD
RUSTIN.
MARSHA P. JOHNSON WAS A
TRANSGENDER ACTIVIST SHE WAS AN
OUTSPOKEN ADVOCATE FOR GAY
RIGHTS IN A PROMINENT LEADER
DURING THE STONEWALL UPRISING.
BAYARD RUSTIN WAS A LEADER IN
THE SOCIAL MOVEMENTS FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS GAY RIGHTS AND NON
VIOLENCE HE WAS AN ADVISER TO
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
DURING THE MONTGOMERY BUS
BOYCOTT HE WAS ALSO AN ORGANIZER
FOR THE MARCH ON WASHINGTON.
OF ALL THE LEADERS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT BAIRD WORK IN
THE DEEP DEEP SHADOWS BECAUSE IT
WAS TOO MUCH OF A LIABILITY TO
BE WHO HE WAS.
DUE LARGELY IN PART OF THESE
EARLY TROUT TRAILBLAZERS AND
THEIR COURAGE THERE ARE BLACK
LGBT Q. INDIVIDUALS ADVOCATING
FOR ECONOMIC SECURITY HIV AND
HEALTH EQUALITY RELIGIOUS
TOLERANCE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND THE NATION I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORD AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS WALDRON
YOU RECOGNIZE AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
NINETEEN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
DESIGNATED FEBRUARY AS BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IT'S OUR DUTY TO REMEMBER THE
PIONEERS WHO DEVOTED THEIR LIVES
TO THE STRUGGLE FOR EQUITY AND
CIVILITY IN OUR COUNTRY AND
STATE.
WE HONOR OUR HEROES ARTISTS
LEADERS ATHLETES AND INVENTORS
OF THE PAST AND CURRENT AND
CELEBRATE THEIR LIFE AND
STRUGGLE.
BUT DESPITE THE TRIUMPHS OF
YESTERDAY OUR FOUNDERS GAVE US
THE TORCH TO CARRY. TO CREATE A
MORE PERFECT UNION.
WE MUST RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO
FIGHTING FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND PROVIDING EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE WHO
LIVES HERE BECAUSE THAT IS TRULY
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
I ENCOURAGE EVERY CALIFORNIANS
TO CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
WITH ZEAL AND ENTHUSIASM
REMEMBERING THE HARD WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE FOR YOU QUALITY.
AND COMMITTING OURSELVES TO THE
WORK LEFT TO DO THANK YOU.
MR GABRIEL RECOGNIZER DESTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUSES PROUD TO JOIN
WITH SO MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE
CALIFORNIA UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WOULD NOT BE THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
THOUGHT THE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN SO MANY
FIELDS IN LITERATURE IN ART IN
SCIENCE.
INNER TAIN MENT IN SPORTS IN
MEDICINE IN GOVERNMENT IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT IN BUSINESS IN
THE FIGHT FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY.
IN DEFENSE OF OUR NATION AND IN
SO MANY OTHER CARCASSES PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR ROMMEL'S.
RECOGNIZES IT AS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR.
NINETEEN CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH SERVES AS A
REMINDER OF THE LIBERTIES WE
HAVE GAINED AND THE PRIVILEGES
WE ARE STILL FIGHTING.
FOR THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO REMEMBER AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO MADE A DIFFERENCE IN CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR ALL AMERICANS OF
EVERY BACKGROUND.
MINORITY GROUPS AND WALK OF LIFE.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH SHOULD NOT
BE JUST A MONTH WE ACKNOWLEDGE
ON THE FLOOR.
BUT RATHER A CALL TO ACTION A
TIME WHERE WE CAN LOOK BACK AT
OUR COUNTRY'S PAINFUL PAST ON
ITS PEOPLE.
AND RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO LEAD
FOR A BETTER FUTURE.
ALL OF US TODAY HAVE GAIN
PERSPECTIVE AND INSPIRATION FROM
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS WE HAVE
PAVE THE WAY. TO HONOR THEIR
HARD WORK AND SACRIFICES WE MUST
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE TIRELESSLY
AND FIGHT EVERY DAY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR.
NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUR DS.
HANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A C. R..
NINETEEN BLACK WOMEN HAVE BEEN
TRAIL BLAZERS.
SINCE THIS COUNTRY LANDED ON US.
MANY KNOW THE NAMES OF SHIRLEY
CHISHOLM THE MASON HARRIET
TUBMAN.
PIONEERS IN OUR HISTORY WHO RAN
FOR THE HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE
LAND WHO WERE BUSINESS MOGULS
AND MILLIONAIRES AND WHO
ESTABLISHED THE UNDERGROUND
RAILROAD BRINGING SLAVES TO
FREEDOM.
OTHER NAMES OF BLACK WOMEN I'D
LIKE TO SHARE.
BESSIE COLEMAN WHO WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE PILOT
MAGGIE LINO WALKER WHO WAS THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO FORM AND BI
PRESIDENT OF A UNITED STATES
BANK.
AND MERRY CANNER WHO INVENTED
THE SANITARY NAPKIN.
WHILE WE SHOULD LEARN ABOUT AND
CELEBRATE AS MANY BLACK WOMEN AS
POSSIBLE WHO HAVE CHARTERED THE
COURSE OF HISTORY FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE CONTINUE
CHALLENGES THAT BLACK WOMEN
CONTINUE TO FACE EVERY DAY.
WE ARE OVER REPRESENTED IN OUR
PRISON WE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY IMPLICIT BIAS WE ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED IN SENIOR
LEADERSHIP ACROSS ALL SECTORS
AND WE ARE STILL MARGINALIZED IN
PAY EQUITY.
IN REPRESENTATION IN ELECTED
OFFICE AND WE RECEIVE SIXTY ONE
CENTS TO THE WHITE MALE DOLLAR.
AND YET WE ARE ALWAYS AND
CONTINUED TO ACT WE ARE ALWAYS
ASKED TO TOW THE LINE AND CARRY
THE WATER ON SO MANY ISSUES AND
CAUSES.
SO IT IS IN THIS HOUSE.
THAT WE CAN RECOGNIZE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THE STRUGGLE AND
THE PAIN OF BLACK WOMEN AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS DURING THIS
MONTH.
AND HONOR THAT IN THE POLICY
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE ON
THE HISTORY ON THE COLOR AND ON
THE FUTURE OF THIS STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR.
NINETY SEEING AND HEARING.
NO OTHERS WISHING TO SPEAK
DOCTOR WHEREVER YOU MAY CLOSE IN
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. FOR ALL OF THEIR
COMMENTS AND THEIR SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW I ALSO LIVE IN A WORLD
OF WHAT IF.
WHAT IF THINGS HAD BEEN
DIFFERENT?
WHAT WOULD THE WORLD TODAY LOOK
LIKE?
AND THEN OFTENTIMES I'M REMINDED
OF HOW FAR WE'VE COME AND YET
HOW LITTLE WE'VE GAINED.
THIS PAST WEEK WE HAVE ALL BEEN
REELING OVER WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN VIRGINIA.
AND THE PEOPLE ASK THE QUESTION
WHAT SHOULD WE DO.
DEALING WITH BLACK FACE.
AND THE KKK UNIFORM OUTFIT.
AND I'M OFTEN I HAVE TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT NOTHING HAPPENS IN
THIS WORLD BY ACCIDENT.
THE THINGS WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE
HAVE A PURPOSE IN THE DESIGN AND
WE GET THE RESULTS.
OF THAT ACTION.
YOU SEE I'M NOT THAT CONCERNED I
THINK ABOUT BLACK FACING KKK
UNIFORMS IN VIRGINIA.
BECAUSE I DEALT WITH THAT AND
YOU SEE LA I DEALT WITH THAT
ALSO MOST RECENTLY UCSD.
WITH THE COMPTON COOK OUT.
IN TWENTY IN.
TWENTY TEN THAT HAPPENED ON
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
WELL YOUNG PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS
FUNNY TO MIMICKED AND TO
CHARACTERIZE INC AND MAKE
CHARACTERS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
I DEALT WITH THAT REGULARLY AT
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY WHEN
WE WOULD HAVE OUR SLAVE AUCTIONS
THAT AYE FRATERNITIES.
AND PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT WAS THAT
WE WERE OVERLY SENSITIVE TO THE
ISSUES THAT WITH THE AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I DEALT WITH THAT WHEN WE'VE I
PURCHASED MY FIRST HOME IN SAN
DIEGO.
IN OAK PARK VERY COMMON WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITY.
ONLY TO GO THROUGH FOR THE DAY
OF INSPECTION TO SEE A TO
APPROVE THE HOUSE.
DISCOVERED IN THE MASTER BEDROOM
KKK WAS CARVED INTO THE DOOR OF
THE CLOSET.
FROM THE TOP TO THE BOTTOM.
AND THE ONLY CLAIM HE DIDN'T SEE
THAT INITIALLY.
SO WE ARE CONSTANTLY CONFRONTED
WITH THE REALITY THAT RACISM IS
DEEP IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT HAS A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
EVERYTHING.
ON HEALTH CARE ONE EDUCATION ON
VARIOUS OPPORTUNITIES AND THINGS
THAT WE MEET EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AND WE CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
JUST TURN OUR EYES AND LOOK AWAY.
BECAUSE THE LACK OF EDUCATION IS
INTENTIONAL.
IT IS FOR THAT LACK OF EDUCATION
THE FACT THAT WE WOULD BE
HUMANIZED IN THE HISTORY OF
AFRICANS WERE TAKEN AWAY.
WHEN YOU'LL GO TO EGYPT AND YOU
SEE THE HISTORY OF THIS OF
CIVILIZATION?
DONE BY AFRICANS A NEW CALL
INSIDE OF THE TUNES AND YOU SEE.
THAT THE COLOR IS STILL THERE
BECAUSE OF THE BRILLIANCE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKES THE COLORS.
THOUSANDS OF YEARS LATER.
AND YOU HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THE
BRILLIANCE OF THE INDIVIDUALS
YET THAT HISTORY IS OFTEN STOLEN.
AND HEAR FROM THOSE WHO NEED IT
SO MUCH.
BUT IT ALSO GIVES THOSE WHO
REFUSED TO DO THE HISTORY.
THE COMFORT AND THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO DE HUMANIZE. TO LIMIT.
AND OFTENTIMES TO DESTROY
GENERATIONS AND GENERATIONS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN TERMS OF
THEIR SELF ESTEEM.
I CALL FOR YOU TODAY BECAUSE NOT
TO JUST SIMPLY SAY THIS IS BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
BUT TO RECOGNIZE A POLICIES OF
THIS HOUSE IN THIS STATE.
THAT CONTINUED TO DE HUMANIZE
AFRICAN AMERICANS.
THE FACT THAT WE CAN SHOOT
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND HAVE NO
REMORSE.
IS AN ONGOING CHALLENGE TO THE
HEART.
AND THE SPIRIT OF THIS HOUSE.
AND THE STATION.
THAT WE CAN HAVE THINGS HAPPEN
THAT WE WOULD NOT ALLOW HAPPEN
ANYWHERE ELSE.
AND FEEL NO REMORSE.
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN CHILDREN
ARE AT THE BOTTOM OF ACHIEVEMENT
IN THE STATE.
AND THERE IS NOT OUTRAGE.
OUTRAGE FROM THOSE OF US WHO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
ESTABLISH THE GREATEST
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
IS A CLEAR EXAMPLE THAT WE DO
NOT KNOW THE HISTORY OF THE
PEOPLE WE ENSLAVED.
THE PEOPLE WHO BUILT BILL BUILT
THE FIRST LIBRARIES IN THE WORLD.
WE WE DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND THE
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO HAVE THE HIGHEST
LITERACY RATE IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN HUNDREDS BECAUSE OF
THEIR BELIEF IN LITERACY AND
READING.
BUT THERE ARE THE ONES WHO
CREATED SUNDAY SCHOOL SO THEY
COULD TEACH THE FORMER SLAVE TO
READ.
BUT THEY BILL BLACK COLLEGES
WHEN WE WOULD NOT ALLOW THEIR
CHILDREN TO GO TO COLLEGE
BECAUSE WHY THEY BELIEVED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
MORE THAN SOMETIMES OF FARMERS
AND OTHERS WHO TOOK FOR GRANTED
THEIR WHITE STATUS WOULD ALWAYS
PROTECT THEM.
SO WHEN WE BEGIN TO SAY YES WE
BELIEVE IN THE RESOLUTION WE
HAVE TO BEGIN THE WORK.
AND THAT WORK IS TO CHANGE THE
THE HISTORY OF THIS STATE AND
THIS NATION.
WE CONSISTENTLY PUT TOGETHER
PROPOSALS CONCERNING ETHNIC
STUDIES AND BLACK HISTORY AND
THE CHICANO KISSED HISTORY THAT
SHOULD BE TAUGHT IN THE STATE.
AND WE ALWAYS COME UP WITH THE
SAME CONCLUSION IT COSTS TOO
MUCH.
I'VE BEEN TOLD IT IGNORES IS
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
KNOWLEDGE.
THAT IT HAS PROFOUND IMPACT ON
OUR LIVES.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS TO DO BETTER.
IT HAS TO BEGIN TO SAY WE MUST
CHANGE HOW WE TEACH HISTORY.
AND IT MAY TAKE AWHILE BUT IT IS
WORTH DOING.
WE HAVE BEEN RAISING THIS ISSUE
FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS IN THE
STATE SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
ETHNIC STUDIES.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IF WE HAD TAKEN ACTION
FIFTY YEARS AGO. TO CHANGE HOW
WE EDUCATE AT THE UNIVERSITY
IT'S HOW WE EDUCATE OUR TEACHERS
AND EVENTUALLY WORK DOWN TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
BASICALLY HAVE A CURRICULUM THAT
IS A FULL CURRICULUM OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
IN OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT TIME IS
UP?
WE HAVE BEEN FACED WITH THE
REALITY AS WE LOOK AT THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN VIRGINIA
AND ELSEWHERE THAT RACISM IS
ALIVE AND WELL AND GETTING FAT
IN THIS NATION.
AND WE CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
SIMPLY HAVE RESOLUTIONS THAT
CALL FOR US TO KNOW OUR HISTORY.
WE MUST BEGIN THE ACTION OF
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY CHILD
KNOWS IT.
THAT WE STAND BY IT AND THAT
WHEN WE DO THAT WE CHANGE WHO WE
ARE.
AND WE CHANGE THE FUTURE FOR
CHILDREN TO COME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
OF ACR.
NINETY THAT THE FIRST GOAL IS
NOT ONLY OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
BUT FOR THOSE WHO PLAN TO TAKE
ACTION IN THE STATE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED.
WILL MOVE TO THE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
DOCTOR WEBER HAS ASKED A CO
AUTHORS ON THIS MEASURE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CO AUTHORS.
ONE ACR.
NINETY MEMBERS IS THE CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CALL CLOSE THE ROLE.
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION LIKE TO MOVE
TO A VOICE VOTE ALL IN FAVOR
[inaudible]
ALL OPPOSE.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
HAS BEEN ADOPTED [inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
AS IT IS A TRADITION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
THAT TODAY WE SHOW RECOGNIZED ON
SONG HEROES TO MARK BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
IN THE INTERVENING YEARS SINCE.
NINETEEN SIXTY THE QUEST FOR
JUSTICE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND ALL AMERICANS HAS CONTINUE.
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS THE
LBC THE STAFF WAS THE UNSUNG
HEROES AWARD.
OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH TO
RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
BODIES.
THOSE WHO HAVE MADE SELFLESS
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE CONTINUE THIS TRADITION.
WITH A STELLAR GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WE WILL HONOR
HERE ON THIS FLOOR TODAY.
I WILL LIKE TO APPOINT AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE. TO BRING OUR REACHED
ON TO THE FLOOR WITH A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS TO RETIRE TO THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBERS AS I CALL YOUR NAME.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BURKE
[inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
MCCARTY
.
ALSO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO
ASK.
OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON.
REPUBLICAN LEADER MARIE WALDRON.
R. C. O. B. C. CAUCUS CHAIR DR
SHIRLEY WEBER TO MOVE TO THE
CENTER OF THE AISLE TO RECEIVE
OUR HONOREES.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO INTRODUCTION
OF THE UNSUNG HEROES FOR BLACK
HISTORY MONTH THE CLERK WILL
READ.
THE HONOREE FROM THE SIXTY
SECOND DISTRICT AS ALBIA MOSIS
SHE IS ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE.
ALTHEA MOSES IS A BEST SELLING
AUTHOR AND COACH FOR HEALTH AND
FITNESS SUCCESS.
ALTHEA HAS CREATED A VITAL
ENTERPRISE IS DEVOTED TO
EMPOWERING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO
LOSE WEIGHT.
GET FIRM AND STRIP IN OUR MIND
SPIRIT BODIES INTO LIVE FEEL
.
WE HONOR YOU FROM THE NIGHT
DISTRICT IS UPON OUR WALKER
SHE'S ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
YUVAN WALKER IS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN PRESIDENT
OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION LOCAL.
ONE THOUSAND MISS WALKER HAS
USED A LEADERSHIP SKILLS SHE
GAINED WHILE SERVING IN THE
MARINE CORPS TO LEAD THE BATTLE
FOR FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS FOR
STATE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
.
WE ARE REVIEWS FROM THE FORTY
FIRST DISORDER DOCTORS DAVID AND
JACQUELINE JACOBS THEY ARE
SUPPORTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDER.
DOCTORS DAVID AND JACQUELINE
JACOB SO BOTH RETIRED EDUCATORS
AT SERVING VOLUNTEER LEADERSHIP
ROLES IS SCOTT UNITED METHODIST
CHURCH THE ASP WIRES WEST
PASADENA PROGRAM.
AND THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
COMMITTEE COALITION WHICH
FOCUSES ON THE LEGACY OF DR KING
[inaudible]
THE HONOREE THIS WEEK IS WANNA
ROSE OKAY VERO SHE IS ESCORTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
WANNA ROSA GUERRERO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM.
WITH A STRONG COMMITMENT TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE DISCOVER --
HAS DEDICATED HER CAREER TO CALL
CREATING TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE
WITH A MYRIAD OF COMMUNITIES
THAT SUPPORT AND ADVANCE
POSITIVE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
.
WE ARE RE FROM THE SEVENTH
DISTRICT IS ALEX DID BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
ALEXANDER WHITE IS AN EXPERIENCE
LANGUAGE ARTS PROFESSOR AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE.
SHE HAS A DEMONSTRATED HISTORY
OF IMPROVING THE ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES OF THREE HUNDRED PLUS
STUDENTS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS.
THIS WHITE IS A PASSIONATE AND
ENGAGE COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AN
ACTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF THE SELF --
PARK COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
.
THE HONOREE FROM THE SIXTY
FOURTH DISTRICT IS ON THREE
SPICER HE'S ESCORTED BY SIMPLY
RIVER GIPSON.
ANDREAS MARSHALL WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN COPLEY CALIFORNIA.
ON THREE LAUNCH THE INTERNET
BASED RADIO STATION THE HUB
RADIO TEN YEARS AGO WITH A
VISION TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
FOR THE BETTER.
THE RADIO STATION ALSO SERVES AS
A CREATIVE SPACE FOR STUDENTS
AND BUSINESS OWNERS ALIKE
.
BONTA REVIEWS FROM A SEVEN NIGHT
THIS WORKER REVEREND WINDOW BASS
AND DR ANGELA BASS.
THEIR ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER.
DR ANGELA BASSETT REVERENT
WINDOW BASS HAVE A COMBINED
SERVICE OF EIGHTY SIX YEARS IN
EDUCATION SERVING STUDENTS
TEACHERS PARENTS AND SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES NOT ONLY IN THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUT IN DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION. ONE
OF THEIR MANY NOTEWORTHY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDES
DEVELOPING A BLUEPRINT TO
ACCELERATE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND AFRICAN
STUDIES WHICH HAS BEEN ADOPTED
BY THE DISTRICT
.
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY'S SESSION
JOHNNY RANGE THE IS THE ARTERY
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FIFTY NINE ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
ON THE FLOOR.
FOR THE CEREMONY TODAY.
ON YOUR DESK THERE IS A MOMENTO --
A CALENDAR ENTITLED BLACK
HISTORY.
FROM SLAVE. TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE ALSO WANT ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TAKE A FEW MOMENTS.
AND PLEASE EXIT PLEASE OF LOOK
AND GO TO THE SECOND FLOOR TANDA
AND VIEW OUR EXHIBIT AT YOUR
LEISURE.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY AS
HONOR RES.
PLEASE RISE AND EXIT THE
CHAMBERS MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
THEM A ROUND [inaudible]
APPLAUSE.
ZERO TO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MEMBERS ANNOUNCEMENTS
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH FLOOR
SESSION TEN THIRTY AM. FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS.
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY.
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH THE CHECK IN
SESSION ON FRIDAY FRIDAY
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS A NINE AM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED A GERMAN TO MEMORY.
MEMBERS A QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED.
THE QUORUM CALLS NOT LIFTED AT
THIS TIME.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
WILL BE A CHURNING IN THE MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART TODAY.
TWO GERMAN MEMORY MY FRIEND AND
FORMER COLLEAGUE MICHAEL
ROBERTSON.
WHO PASSED AWAY AFTER A HARD
FOUGHT BATTLE WITH CANCER ON
OCTOBER THIRTIETH?
TWENTY EIGHTEEN A FEW DAYS SHY
OF HIS FORTY SECOND BIRTHDAY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE THE
HAIR AND THEIR TWENTY MONTH OLD
SON WALLY.
HIS PARENTS JOHN AND KAREN
ROBERTSON HIS SISTER JAMIE AND A
HOST OF OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
LOVED HIM.
MICHAEL IS A CALIFORNIA NATIVE.
OF FRESNO BOY.
WHERE HE GRADUATED IS BOTH
VALEDICTORIAN AND BASEBALL STAR
FROM BULLARD HIGH SCHOOL IN?
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE MICHAEL WAS
A DEDICATED AND PASSIONATE
PUBLIC SERVANT WHO LEARNED
LESSONS ABOUT SERVING OTHERS.
FROM HIS FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
AND WHO CARRIED THESE PRINCIPLES
WITH HIM AS HE ATTENDED UC
BERKELEY WHERE HE PLAYED
BASEBALL.
COLGATE UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW
AND ULTIMATELY TO WORK FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IN THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND
FOR MICHAEL GOT INTO HIS CAR AND
DROVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
CHICAGO.
WITH NO PROMISE OF A PAID JOB.
BUT A STRONGLY HELD BELIEF IN
SERVICE. TO WORK FOR A LONG SHOT
CANDIDATE FOR THE U. S. SENATE
NAMED BARACK OBAMA.
THAT BEGAN A FOURTEEN YEAR
CAREER WITH THE PRESIDENT.
HE WORKED ON A SENATE CAMPAIGN
IN HIS SENATE OFFICE ON HIS TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
IN HIS ADMINISTRATION SERVING AS
CHIEF OF STAFF AT THE UNITED
STATES GENERAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION.
DEPUTY CABINET SECRETARY AND
DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
FINALLY A SENIOR ADVISER TO THE
US DEPARTMENT OF TREASURY.
HE WAS ONE OF THE LONGEST
SERVING MEMBERS OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S TEAM.
WHILE SERVING IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION MICHAEL HAD A KEY
ROLE IN WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
AND IT WAS DURING THIS TIME THAT
HE WAS ALSO GOING THROUGH HIS
OWN CANCER TREATMENT.
USING HIS OWN PERSONAL STORY HE
PIERCED THROUGH THE POLITICS AND
GAVE A HUMAN FACE TO THE DEBATE
ABOUT HEALTHCARE.
FIERCELY ADVOCATING THAT
EVERYONE DESERVE QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE CARE.
AS PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID.
MICHAEL WAS DRIVEN AND DEDICATED
A CONSTANT SOURCE OF WISDOM AND
KINDNESS SOMEONE WHO JUMPED INTO
PUBLIC SERVICE BECAUSE HE
BELIEVED HIS EFFORTS.
COULD HELP CHANGE THIS COUNTRY
FOR THE BETTER.
I LIKE EVERYONE ELSE WHO HAD THE
HONOR OF WORKING ALONGSIDE
MICHAEL IN OUR EXTENDED OBAMA
FAMILY WITNESS THIS WISDOM AND
KINDNESS.
EVERY TIME WE INTERACTED WITH
HIM.
MICHAEL ALWAYS STROVE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING YOU WANTED TO HELP
WITH HUMOR AND GRACE EVEN WHEN
IT WAS HARD.
MICHAEL ROBERTS AND WAS A LOVING
SON.
A DEVOTED HUSBAND AND FATHER A
TRUE FRIEND.
AND A DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT.
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED.
I ASK THIS HOUSE TO ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MS WICKS.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM THE ENTIRE.
COMMUNITY OF FRESNO CALIFORNIA
AND BEYOND.
JOIN ME TODAY IN ASKING YOU TO
HONOR THE LIFE OF A TRUE LEADER
WITHIN THE FRESNO.
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
OFFICER PIA.
BANG.
OFFICER BANG WAS A TWENTY SIX
YEAR VETERAN OF THE DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS A LEADER AMONG HIS PEERS.
AND WITHIN THE MON COMMUNITY.
IN FACT HE WAS ONE OF FRESNO IS
VERY FIRST.
MON OFFICERS.
THIS WAS A MAJOR SOURCE OF PRIDE
FOR HE AND HIS FAMILY FOR HIS
FRIENDS.
BUT ALSO FOR FRESNO AND THE
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS A MAJOR ASSET TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF VERY IMPORTANT
INTER ACTIONS AND COMMUNITY
POLICING WITHIN THE LONG
COMMUNITY.
AS MAYOR OF FRESNO I HAD THE
DELIGHT.
OF HANDING HIM HIS BADGE.
AS IS THE CUSTOM AT THE FRESNO
POLICE DEPARTMENT A NEW OFFICERS
COME ON BOARD.
AND THEN FAMILY MEMBERS.
ARE ASKED TO COME FORWARD.
AND PEN THE BADGE.
ON THE OFFICER [inaudible]
OFFICER VANG.
TOOK THAT BADGE.
AND SERVED IN SO MANY CAPACITIES
TIME DOESN'T ALLOW WALL.
BUT HERE'S A FEW MORE THAN TWO
DECADES WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
ASSIGNED TO THE MULTI AGENCY
GANG ENFORCEMENT CONSORTIUM. TO
THE PATROL UNITS AND TO NEIGHBOR
HANG NEIGHBORHOOD POLICING.
HIS FELLOW OFFICERS HAVE SAID
THEY'LL MISS HIS SMILE.
HIS GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR.
HIS STRONG WORK ETHIC
[inaudible]
BECAUSE WE KNOW IN THE FRESNO
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
BAD ALTHOUGH OFFICERS CARRY
[inaudible]
THE BADGE.
THE FAMILY CARRIES THE WEIGHT.
AND SO THAT PENDING CEREMONY.
AND NOW AN ENTIRE FAMILY OF
RESIDENTS.
MOURN HIS LOSS.
WE LOST OFFICER BANG LAST WEEK.
AFTER HIS TRUCK WAS HIT HEAD ON
BY A WRONG WAY DRIVER.
HE WAS ON HIS WAY HOME AT THE
END OF HIS SHIFT.
HE WAS STILL IN UNIFORM.
FIRST RESPONDERS REALIZED.
VAN WAS AN OFFICER.
AND AT THE SCENE.
COVERED HIS BODY WITH AN
AMERICAN FLAG.
A PROCESSION OF FRESNO PD C. H.
P. AND CAL FIRE PERSONNEL.
ESCORTED OFFICER BANG FROM THE
CRASH SCENE. TO THE FRESNO
CORONER'S OFFICE.
THOSE SAME OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS STOOD AT ATTENTION.
AND SALUTED HIS FLAG DRAPED BODY.
AS HE WAS TAKEN INSIDE THE
CORONER'S OFFICE [inaudible]
WE LOST [inaudible]
HANG. FORTY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
WE LOST A PIONEER.
WE LOST A TRUE COMMUNITY.
POLICE OFFICER AND A MAN THAT
LEFT BEHIND.
A LEGACY OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
PROTECT.
AND TO SERVE.
HE LEAVES BEHIND A BELOVED WIFE
AND FOUR CHILDREN.
AND A LARGE EXTENDED FAMILY.
HE ALSO LEAVES BEHIND AN ENTIRE
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
OF GREETING GRIEVING BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND A ALSO LEAVES BEHIND A
MORNING COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
IN.
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO ADJOURN THIS AUGUST FLOOR.
IN THE MEMORY OF P. OF BANK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON.
THIS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU ARE I SEE A TURN IN
THE MEMORY OF THIS IS THE LOTUS
LAUNCHES OF MONTEBELLO.
DAUGHTER FENCES WAS BORN ON MAY
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE AND PASSED AWAY IN JANUARY
TWENTY THIRD.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE LOTUS
SANCHEZ AND A HUSBAND OR TO THE
SCIENCES WERE MERRY FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND REYES THREE
DAUGHTERS ELISABETH.
MONICA AND SYLVIA AND I'M
NUMEROUS GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
WHEN ONE OF THEIR GRANDDAUGHTERS
IS BORN WITH THE SERIOUS HEART
DEFECT?
THE LOTUS WORK TO RAISE MONEY
FOR HER SURGERY.
SINCE OUR THE GRAND DAUGHTERS
AGNO THIS LOTUS WERE
CONTINUOUSLY AND TIRES THE TO
FIND RECENT REPORT THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION.
THE LOTUS HAD A GIFT OR CURSE
SHANE AND USE OUR SPECIAL TALENT
TO MAKE AND DONATE HUNDREDS OF
BEANIE BABIES FOR GREAT CAUSES.
LITTLEST HELPED WITH EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT THE LA COUNTY AND IN
NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS.
AND IN THE NEIGHBORING DISTRICT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BALLING PARK
WILL HIGHLIGHT HER WONDERFUL
WORK WITHIN THERE'S AN ME
TREMENDOUS EFFORTS TO HELP THOSE
IN NEED. FOR EXAMPLE SHE HAD
RECENTLY HELPED A FAMILY WITH
FOUR YOUNG CHILDREN THE YOUNGEST
ONLY A NEWBORN.
THE CHILDREN WERE A WORLD IN THE
MONEY BILL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHEN THEIR FATHER WAS
SHOT TO DEATH WHILE COLLECTING
CANS AND BOTTLES IN AN ALLEY TO
SUPPLEMENT THEIR INCOME.
THE LOTUS ORGANIZED A CAMPAIGN
TO ADOPT THE FAMILY THEY WERE
HELP WITH IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND
PROVIDED TOYS AND CLOTHES FOR
CHRISTMAS.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND ARE TOO LOW
ALSO DONATED DOESN'T THE DANCES
AND TOYS TO THE HIGHWAY PATROL
AT CHRISTMAS TIME FOR
UNDERSERVED CHILDREN.
THE LOTUS IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND ARE TO THE FLANGES HER
DAUGHTERS ELIZABETH MONICA AND
SYLVIA.
INNER GRANDCHILDREN WHOM SHE
ADORED TREMENDOUSLY.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH THE FAMILY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE LOTUS
ON TO THIS NUMBER.
EIGHTY THANK YOU MISTER SIMMONS
RUBIO YOU ARE ALSO RECOGNIZE ON
THE C. DRAMA MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY DURING THE MEMORY OF
THE LOWER SANCHEZ WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY TWENTY THIRD.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY THREE THE
LARA'S WAS VERY ACTIVE IN MY
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
CAME TO HELPING SUPPORT OUR
VETERANS.
THE LARA'S CROCHETED OVER FIVE
FIVE HUNDRED BEANIES WHICH WERE
DONATED TO THE U. S. SO I DON'T
TERRY OUR AIRPORT TO BE GIVEN.
TO TO BE GIVEN TWO RETURNING
TRIPS.
THE LARGER DELORES ALSO CREATED
IN CROCHETED GOLD STAR AND THE
STAR BANNERS AND NINE ELEVEN
BANNER TO BE USED AT MANY
CEREMONIES COUNTRY COUNTY WIDE.
SHE DONATED MANY CROCHETED
BLANKETS TO SUCH AS ADVANCE.
THE AMERICAN LEGION LADIES
AUXILIARY DHARTI UNIT A THIRTY
BY HISPANIC AMERICAN AIRBORNE
ASSOCIATION LADIES.
AND LARA MODEL VETERANS.
THE LORD'S LOVE TO VOLUNTEER AT
RESURRECTION CEMETERY CALVARY
CEMETERY OAK HILL CEMETERY QUEEN
OF HAVE OF HEAVEN CEMETERY
FOREST LAWN IN MOUNT SINAI
CEMETERIES.
SHE WAS THERE AT LEAST TWICE A
WEEK.
SHE WOULD ASSIST HER HUSBAND OUR
OUR TOTAL WHEN HE WOULD PERFORM
MILITARY HONORS WITH THE VALLEY
VETERANS MEMORIAL TEAM.
SHE LITERALLY ATTENDED HUNDREDS
OF FUNERALS LOCALLY.
LARA MODEL VETERANS MEET AT VFW
POST NINETEEN FORTY FOUR ON
GALLON THE CITY OF INDUSTRY.
THE LAWRENCE WAS THERE AT LEAST
TWICE A MONTH USUALLY MORE.
THE LARA'S TRAVELED WITH GLAMOUR
MODEL VETERANS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
TO THE BALLOT BALBOA NAVAL
HOSPITAL IN SAN DIEGO. TO FEED
THE HOSPITALIZED VETERANS THERE.
DILLER'S CROCHET TWO HUNDRED
BEANIES FOR THE GIFT BAGS THAT
WERE HANDED OUT THAT DAY TO THE
GREAT FOR VETERANS.
DELORES PARTICIPATED IN WELCOME
HOME VIETNAM VETERANS APPROACH
TO HEALTH MEMORIAL PARK IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN DOLLARS HELP WITH THE
JIM ROSE ANNUAL THANKSGIVING
DINNER. FOR HOSPITALIZED
VETERANS OPPOSED EIGHTY SEVENTY
IN THIS IS A OVER TWO HUNDRED
VETERANS WERE BUSED IN FROM
SEVERAL HOSPITALS.
DELORES WOULD HELP EACH AND
EVERY TIME SHE WAS ASKED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A DURING A
MEMBER MEMORY OF DOLLARS
SENTENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DEATHS REPORTED IN THE
JOURNAL REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING HARRY NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GLORIA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY
FEBRUARY TWELFTH AT TEN THIRTY
AM IN THE QUORUM CALLS LIFTED